[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
here is an interesting free speech story
there is a Texas woman who is saying
that she was targeted and cyber bullied
by a sheriff because she had an F Trump
sticker on the back of her truck and she
is saying not only is she not backing
down but she's going to be filing a
lawsuit she has a GMC Sierra pickup
nothing more patriotic than that but
Karen Fonseca doesn't like Donald Trump
so she has a sticker that says F Trump
and f you for voting for him without any
kind of bleep Serb dashed out letters
and she says that police were frequently
sort of paying attention to her back of
the truck decal police have pulled her
over but she argues and I believe is
true the bumper sticker another bumper
sticker the window sticker is protected
by something called the Constitution the
guarantee of speed of free speech and
that mostly cops would pull her over
talk to her about it but then let her go
without much of a hassle but that
changed last week when Fort Bend County
Sheriff Troy Nell's posted a photo of
the truck and the sticker on his
personal Facebook page saying that
unhappy locals were complaining to him
about it and his post said that the
county prosecutor was considering
charging the trucks owner with
disorderly conduct saying if you know
whose truck this is or if it's yours I
want to talk about it with you and of
course free speech advocates said no no
no you can't do this and this caused the
Republican sheriff to retreat the
Facebook post was deleted a day or two
later and the sheriff said he was done
talking about it
however that ended up becoming something
that escalated there was a news
conference outside the Fort Bend County
Justice Center earlier this week and
Miss Fonseca slammed the sheriff who's
considering running for Congress and
said that this was a total political
stunt saying I'm just one person here
but I'm being used as bait for the
potential congressman's political gain
etc etc investigators
the Sheriff's Office then got a tip that
Fonseca had an outstanding felony
warrant for fraud according to a
department spokeswoman and then they
arrested her and she was ultimately
released after posting $1500 bail
so this is one of those situations where
hey listen she had an outstanding
warrant and if any Department becomes
aware of that it is completely within
their rights to go and arrest the woman
however when you hear that [ __ ] law
enforcement was clearly not pleased with
the woman's bumper sticker a political
bumper sticker an anonymous tip comes in
that the woman has this warrant against
her and then she gets arrested any
normal person is going to wonder whether
this was all an inside job by law
enforcement yeah I mean I think it's
pretty obvious what happened they wanted
to arrest her or you know punish her in
some way for disorderly conduct yeah and
when they found out that they couldn't
because of this small thing called the
First Amendment to the ISIS Constitution
yeah they realized they had lost the
first battle there but this was their
chance to win the second battle and get
back at her yeah which is making her
experience some bad times I guess it
would be now I don't know anything about
the fraud charges I am by no means
telling you that this woman has never
committed any crime all I'm telling you
is that it's abundantly clear and the
ACLU has made it clear and every every
free speech organization has made it
clear there is nothing wrong with a with
a sticker that says eff Trump on your
car a period that that's it I mean it's
just so open and shut yeah there is
precedent for this stuff and you know
maybe you'd may think well you have the
F word just out in public and as a
natural number of children may see it
you have seen court cases before this
has been settled yeah totally okay it's
not broadcast standards that are being
violated that are set by the FCC this is
just someone existing in the world and
they have a bumper sticker and they're
allowed to do that period so I hope she
does sue whatever the the reality is of
these fraud allegations and again nobody
is defending the woman and saying she's
not guilty of fraud right the question
here is was this a planned way to screw
this woman over when law enforcement
didn't like the fact that she was
driving around with this sticker and
accurately saying that this is bullying
and that she has First Amendment rights
that's the question and any common
citizen can take a picture of it and put
it up on their Facebook account and
derail her sure but because the sheriff
is you know in a position of authority
representing the government he can't do
that representing local government I
guess you would say sheriff's or County
right is that how yeah absolutely right
and hey we'll find out what happens with
the lawsuit I don't know not something I
would ever do though no I don't need
specially not in Texas geez I agree and
I just don't I don't do bumper stickers
because I don't want to attract any
attention on the road you know you never
know what might there's so much road
rage in general in Boston driving is
such a disaster already so I don't want
number one any identifying marks on my
on my car and I don't want and you never
know what might set someone off that's
why I wouldn't even put anything on my
car and saying F Trump is one thing but
saying f you for voting for him I mean
people are gonna get outraged and and by
the way I do endorse other people
putting david pakman show bumper
stickers on their cars just cuz I would
I don't put things on my car for a very
specific reason that's not a double
standard everybody else should have
david pakman show bumper stickers wasn't
there an inspiring story for back of the
day of to david pakman show viewers
meeting each other because of the bumper
sticker yep I believe it was in
Tennessee where someone drove up to a
car and that car had on its bumper a
david pakman show bumper-sticker
and i don't know that they actually
spoke to each other but yeah maybe i
don't remember you could have used the
show as a vehicle yes to get them in
touch a figure a proverbial radical yeah
exactly
okay let's talk about wasted coffee
grounds what do you do pat with wasted
coffee grounds from the keurig like how
does that work you just toss them in the
trash right yeah I just like rinse it
out you know because you have a recycle
do the Renewable curing pod yeah yeah I
basically when I'm done making my
espresso or Chemex or French press you
just throw the coffee grounds in the
trash that's what I do never down the
sink because I've heard that that's bad
for some reason I don't know remember
exactly why no oh you put them in the
sink I cannot confirm do you have a
garbage yeah you do okay well hopefully
that's taken care of it in any case what
do you do with wasted coffee grounds you
can use them to fuel London's buses
Royal Dutch Shell
and another clean a bio beam company in
London says that they are going to be
creating a new biofuel which contains
something called coffee oil and it comes
from spent coffee grounds I love it
what's better than this and reportedly
it makes the bus smell like hazelnut
when you drive around Wow I'm kidding
about that okay that's pretty cool yeah
and I guess like Londoners have upwards
of two cops a coffee every single day
you wouldn't expect that you wouldn't
and that's not that much right them more
as tea drinkers don't some places like
in Italy don't people often have like
four to five espressos in a day or
anything like that sounds bad um I love
this I think this is fantastic a two
hundred thousand tonnes of waste a year
in spent coffee grounds and this can all
be collected from coffee shops factories
blah blah blah blah blah they extract
the coffee oil and then you can burn the
coffee oil when mixed into this biofuel
I think this is absolutely fantastic and
I I'm kidding about the smell of coffee
but I do know that when people do the
what's the name of that conversion you
can do you can convert diesel cars to
run on vegetable oil yeah yeah and when
people do that and they get oil that's
been used in fryers and restaurants it
does actually smell like french fries
when you drive around
I think that's pirate part of the
biofuel mix that's being used in these
buses as well
oh it's also gone with oh I don't know
that interesting so I mean it's
conceivable that it might smell a little
bit like coffee if you have a one in one
of these biofuels which is kind of funny
the last time I went to London I tried
buying coffee and of course I'm not from
England I'm from New England oh you let
me do it a little differently here huh
and I asked for an iced coffee with
cream cuz I was drinking cream at the
time yeah and it was completely
embarrassing for me what was it though I
mean they had no idea what I was talking
about oh they just didn't understand
what you were asking yeah
oh okay it's it's not that they didn't
have they have iced coffee in London not
at the time oh not at the time
relatively new that's just not what you
put in your coffee either
what part of the year was it when that
took place I've been in uh like March
March so it was cold there maybe that's
why they didn't have iced coffee because
why does someone want iced coffee in
March perhaps is it possible because I
think that iced coffees been I don't
think it was a thing I have to tell you
the coffee was not great when I went to
London the best coffee I had in London
was at an Indian restaurant and at an
Italian cafe yeah the the normal I in
fact one morning I remember because I
was there on Christmas last year and a
lot of stuff was closed I remember going
into some pub because they said we're
open and we have coffee and I asked for
a cappuccino and they're like no no we
have really weak crappy drip coffee we
give you and I said I'll take it yeah I
mean Londoners aren't known for their
food and apparently not their coffee
right absolutely right and of course
with peace and love I say it and no
offense meant or anything like that
all normal disclaimers about everybody's
absolutely fantastic but the food in
London was not the best best Indian food
I've had though yes the Indian food I've
had in London Jeanine Pirro our
favourite FoxNews judge behind only
Andrew Napolitano right now I think
Andrew Napolitano is is second - Jeanine
Pirro well they both have trumps the
year they both do that's absolutely true
she was given a court summons over the
weekend for driving 119 miles per hour
in upstate New York listen whatever we
want to say about her politics I am not
comfortable even on the highway driving
a hundred you know there are people who
think it's fun to like get up to a
hundred on the highway or whatever I'm
not comfortable with that this is a 60
something-year-old woman which is a
beautiful age to be but it's it's pretty
pretty generally true that your your
reflexes have slowed down slightly at
that age and that your vision is
typically not as good at that age and
she was going 119 miles per hour in
upstate New York it how did she even get
it in her mind that that was remotely
safe to do right well I mean her excuse
was that she was visiting her 89 year
old ailing mother
yeah and that she had been driving for
hours and she just didn't realize but
shouldn't she know best that ignorant of
the law is not an excuse and also how
did she said she didn't notice how fast
she was going how do you not notice that
you've accidentally gotten it up to 120
like I understand if you're on the
master
Pyke sometimes it starts moving you go
in 83 and that's the flow of traffic and
it's it's a calm day so you don't notice
that hey this has just been the speed
for the last 30 minutes okay
yeah a hundred and nineteen without
noticing and I've driven through like
Montana Wyoming and of course just
straight stretches of road for miles on
end yeah speed limits 80 miles an hour
and I've gotten up to 95 and yeah I'm
like oh wow it's a little bit fast there
yeah slowed it down 119 it's
unimaginable to me that you might just
get up to that speed I will by the way
you did you have anything else you
wanted to say about judge Jeanine no no
okay
this reminds me that a next weekend I
will be going for the first time to the
state of Indiana and I am going it's not
for a great positive thing I'm going
because a family member of my
girlfriend's has passed away and there's
going to be a memorial service but it is
going to be a sociological experience
the likes of which I don't know that I'm
prepared for because on this trip I will
be driving through rural Indiana I'm
gonna have a rental car and will be
driving through rural Indiana and I'm
told it's just flat long stretches of
straight highways I will be attending
church in Indiana because this memorial
service is at a pretty what word do I
want to use it's at a it's at a pretty
conservative devout evangelical church
I'm going to be a Jewish Argentinean
David Pakman is going to be at an
evangelical church in Indiana well maybe
you'll become born-again not this may be
so not this week and I will be avoiding
any fast-food restaurants and I've
already been told listen some of these
parts of Indiana the best thing you're
going to get is like an Applebee's or
something like that and I have already
been looking ahead and I found that
within 20 minutes I will always have
more reasonable local restaurants
available if need be because that's a
big thing I don't want to end up
breaking my now like 70
your streak of not having gone to any
kind of fast food right or those types
of restaurants so that's a major concern
but I expect to come back with endless
interesting stories you should do an
episode on location yeah that's an
interesting it's over the weekend you
know or maybe during the drive I could
just set up my phone and go live to
YouTube yeah something like that
and I mean you wouldn't be able to see
anything other than me driving in a car
but well we did have that caller a few
months back who are saying that you know
a lot of progressive hosts don't know
what's going on in the middle of the
country well I'm going to find out I'm
going to find out that's exactly right
can't say I didn't try so anyway that's
next week and not this weekend this
weekend is Thanksgiving this will be
next weekend in December will not
interrupt the show whatsoever will be a
very short trip just during the weekend
and then it all goes well with my
flights I will be back and not just any
other show alright that's it for today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]